When you see some of the monsters
and entities they try to contain,
it’s easy to think of The SCP Foundation as
“the good guys.” And granted, when you observe
the magnitude of threats like the Scarlet
King, it’s hard for anyone to not look like
a downright moral paragon in comparison.
But the Foundation aren’t always knights
in shining armor – sometimes, they themselves
have committed horrific atrocities in order to
keep their supernatural subjects under wraps, and
keep the rest of us safe from anomalous terror.
Nowhere is that more clear than a
deadly incident that occurred in 2010.
The Foundation had been aware of
the Slow Burn Sloth for decades,
and many believe that the entity has existed
for as long as human beings have consumed visual
media. Movies, TV, web pages, and even print
media, like books and magazines, are vulnerable.
Technically speaking, the name “SCP–2774” refers
to whatever visual medium is currently holding
the true entity, known as SCP–2774–A. Thankfully,
SCP–2774–A has never made it onto the Internet,
where it could do truly catastrophic damage, but
the Foundation has prepared for that possibility.
They’ve invented a software
program, Webcrawler A03G32,
designed to constantly monitor all forms of online
visual media for an appearance of SCP–2774–A.
So, what is SCP–2774–A? What could possibly
be so scary that even a picture of it leaking
onto the internet could potentially lead
to the collapse of human civilization?
Simply put, SCP–2774–A is this image of an unknown
humanoid entity in a bizarre sloth costume.
While this picture may seem harmless, that’s
only because it’s black and white, and any red or
green hues have been neutralized from the image.
Anyone who isn’t red-green color blind and somehow
accidentally sees the true version of SCP–2774–A
has a fate far worse than death in store for them.
This is the same fate that would befall almost
the entire population of the Northern Canadian
town of Harper Ridge in 2010. The residents of
this small township were waking up and going
about their morning. Some were getting ready
for work, others enjoying a leisurely breakfast
in front of the television set. All of those
affected had unknowingly made the deadly mistake
of watching the local news that morning.
While the anchor droned on about some
local economic statistics and delivered a dry
advertisement for an upcoming town festival,
the familiar image of something in a sloth
costume appeared briefly on the set behind him.
Most of the Harper Ridge Residents who viewed
the broadcast didn’t even notice the sloth,
but in that fateful instant, almost
every single one of them was doomed.
The Slow Burn Sloth doesn’t always affect everyone
who sees it. Foundation scientists have found that
it generally only affects 40% of people exposed
to it, and doesn’t affect those suffering from
color-blindness at all. However, one of the more
frightening details about the sloth – which is
classified as a memetic image SCP, for its
ability to spread and appear randomly almost
anywhere – is that it grows more powerful and more
contagious with every living victim it affects.
After claiming a significant number of
new victims – say, from a small Canadian
town – SCP–2774–A’s infection rate
can rise to as high as 60%, or beyond.
The residents of Harper Ridge made their own
predator deadlier without even knowing it.
At a nearby Foundation facility, units were
already mobilizing. It was too late for those
who had already seen the Slow Burn Sloth,
but others could potentially be saved if the
situation was contained quickly. In addition to
the Webcrawler constantly monitoring the internet,
the SCP Foundation also had a huge number of
dedicated teams scanning broadcasts worldwide
for potential incidences of SCP–2774–A
exposure. When one of these teams detected
the Sloth’s presence in Harper Ridge’s
morning newscast, and found that upwards
of 4,000 civilians had already been exposed,
they knew that there was no time to waste.
Back in Harper Ridge, the situation was already
deteriorating. A few hours had passed since
the broadcast, and those who were exposed were
beginning to experience strange symptoms already.
First, it was a sense of tiredness and lethargy.
Then, an unusual heaviness to their body,
as though they were experiencing
sudden, extreme muscle fatigue.
People exposed to SCP–2774–A also experienced
clouded cognition – even thinking straight
became a real struggle. It was at this
point that the true effects of witnessing
the Slow Burn Sloth began to take hold,
around six hours after initial exposure.
Little by little, the infected lost all
cognitive functions and higher-level
decision-making abilities. Their bodies
still acted out basic movements very slowly,
seemingly just as a result of muscle memory,
but they had no control over what was going on.
They became, essentially, living zombies, trapped
in their own bodies and only dimly aware of it.
This horrifying experience was completely
consistent with prior Foundation research
into the effects of viewing SCP–2774–A.
And in a twist almost crueler than permanent
zombification, victims of the Slow Burn
Sloth are randomly allocated around 150
seconds of lucidity every 24 hours before
being forced back into their zombified state.
Just as 4,000 of Harper Ridge’s residents
were beginning to experience these effects,
all local communication channels to the
town were cut off by the Foundation.
Well-equipped teams of mobile task force operators
began arriving on the scene shortly after,
accompanied by a number of containment units in
the form of buses and trucks. Luckily for them,
the zombified victims of the Slow Burn Sloth
were incredibly docile and compliant by nature.
Shepherding all 4,000 of them into the containment
units was almost like working with cattle.
Some non-infected local residents attempted to
protest the sudden abduction of their zombified
loved ones. These residents were subdued
and either had their memories wiped with
Foundation Amnestics, or were terminated on site.
Like with almost any conceivable situation,
the SCP Foundation already had measures in
place for a mass exposure event like this.
All in all, a mere 4,000 was still on the
low end of the potential infection scale. The
4,000 victims were secretly taken to Site-116, a
Foundation testing site under the direction of Dr.
Martin and his second in command, Dr. Klara Chung.
There, they’d already been pursuing research on
approximately 2,400 infected subjects
from prior incidents – including
Foundation personnel who were accidentally
infected during the monitoring process.
Thus far, it seemed that the condition caused
by witnessing the Slow Burn Sloth was incurable.
And with 6,400 known living victims situated at
Site-116, SCP–2774–A was at an unprecedented level
of power. All site personnel were instructed
to proceed with caution, and carefully observe
the behavior of their new test subjects.
Dr. Chung spearheaded the majority of the
hands-on research into the infected residents
of Harper Ridge and observed some interesting
phenomena in the victim’s behavioral
patterns as the condition escalated.
The infected subjects, even in their largely
zombified state, developed an almost fanatically
religious obsession with the image of the Slow
Burn Sloth. When left to their own devices, they
would create “idols” of SCP–2774–A, these included
amateur sculptures made of hoarded garbage,
images drawn of the sloth with any
materials they could get their hands on,
or even writing obsessively about the sloth.
Dr. Chung speculated that this behavior was
perhaps an act of appeasement on the victims’
part, hoping to somehow sate the Slow Burn
Sloth and lessen its effects on them through
worship. However, she would later find out that
the truth of the matter was far more disturbing.
Initially, due to their largely docile states,
the subjects imprisoned in Site-116 were given
a relatively long leash. The subjects were even
allocated two hours a day for social interaction
with fellow subjects at mealtimes and during
a designated recreational period. During
these times, the subjects would often trade
their Slow Burn Sloth effigies with one another.
However, Dr. Chung revoked the social interaction
periods and began confining the subjects
to separate Euclid-class containment cells
when violence began to break out between them.
It became clear that, during their 150-second
periods of lucidity every 24-hours, the
subjects would become extremely distressed,
agitated, and even aggressive.
Dr. Chung also ordered any idols,
from trash sculptures to doodles and notes on
fragmented scraps of paper, to be destroyed
immediately. At its new increased power, the
Foundation became concerned that SCP–2774–A
may develop the power to manifest through these
images. No meaningful headway was being made on
a cure for the condition, so something needed
to be done before the situation got out of hand.
In hopes of gaining a better understanding of the
internal processes of Slow Burn Sloth victims,
Dr. Chung decided to conduct a
series of interviews with the
subjects under her care. Two such subjects
- Subject-0866, aka David, and Subject-7444,
aka Claire – were isolated for a 24-hour period,
in hopes of catching them during their daily 150
seconds of lucidity. Dr. Chung and the Foundation
found the results of these two interviews to be
as illuminating as they were utterly terrifying.
When David regained lucidity, he was in a state
of extreme agitation and showed an unsettling
fixation on the clock in the Site-116 interview
room. Under direct questioning from Dr. Chung,
he revealed that Slow Burn Sloth victims are
fully aware of what’s happening during their
zombified periods. He compared the sensation
to being a passenger, trapped and bound in a
vehicle over which they have no control. However,
in this state, victims are also unable to hold a
thought consistently for longer than five seconds.
This leaves them in an almost constant state
of disorientation. Worse still, David described
that victims are subjected to near-constant
hallucinations of the original sloth image,
guiding and controlling their
movements. Almost like a puppeteer.
Thanks to the clock, David was aware of when
his 150 seconds of lucidity were about to
come to an end. After apologizing for what he
was about to do, David lunged at Dr. Chung,
causing a guard present in the interview room
to shoot him dead for Dr. Chung’s protection.
Dr. Chung’s interview with Claire echoed this same
sentiment. During her 150 seconds of lucidity,
Claire first begged to be killed, before divulging
further details about the zombification state.
She would describe hallucinations of the Slow Burn
Sloth stalking her constantly, and controlling her
movements. In some cases, the Sloth would
force her to open her eyes all night, while
it stands next to her bed and screams at her.
As Claire’s 150 seconds of lucidity ended and
she became non-responsive, Dr. Chung put
in a request for Claire’s termination – a
request that was fulfilled three days later.
The third interview with Subject-9225, also known
as Jason, showed that SCP–2774–A appeared to be
manually starting the fights between the subjects
– perhaps even for its own sadistic amusement. He
also stated, before the interview’s conclusion,
that the image of the sloth in his hallucinations
was becoming darker and more tangible. Almost like
it was becoming a real, physical being,
which was an unprecedented phenomenon.
Dr. Chung was, for the first
time in a while, truly afraid.
It seemed, by all accounts, that SCP–2774–A’s
power was growing considerably as a result
of its huge number of active victims. Its
infection rate had likely risen well above 40%,
and its ability to manifest would likely be on
the rise, too. If the Slow Burn Sloth was able to
manifest on a national broadcast, millions would
be infected, to truly apocalyptic results. Dr.
Chung only saw one solution that might curtail the
entity’s growing power, but it wouldn’t be pretty.
She devised a program known as Procedure-XXJ9.
As part of the procedure, additional staff were
brought into Site-116 immediately. The real
purpose of the plan was revealed shortly
afterward: To reduce the number of active
subjects on-site from 6,400 to a mere 200
in hopes of reducing risk. Over the next
several days, staff at Site-116 engaged in
the gruesome task of executing around 6,200
infected subjects via lethal injection.
This was an atrocity so horrific, even by SCP
Foundation standards, that Dr. Chung allowed the
parties involved to use Class-A Amnestics
to erase their memories of being involved
in the mass murder of Site-116’s subjects.
In the aftermath of the cull, the Foundation did
report a decrease in SCP–2774–A’s manifestations
– so Dr. Chung’s procedure did indeed work,
just at a heavy human toll.
The tragic incident of the 2010 Harper Ridge
SCP–2774 Containment Breach is a grim reminder
of just how far the SCP Foundation is willing
to go to do their job. And a reminder to be
careful where you look, because some images
have a much more lasting impact than others…
Now go check out “SCP-5049 - The Skin
Salesman - Demon Dan's Discount Homunculus
Depot” and “The Secret at the Bottom of
SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” for more frightening
anomalous horrors from the SCP Foundation!